all right good morning everybody thank
you for joining this talk over here so I
have with me Mael
anDim
SIM and they are going to talk about
what I think is something extremely
interesting protecting wildlife in
Africa with ai they've told me that this
is really  a passion project of them and
they are also doing their very first
talk so give them a very big round of
[Applause]
applause thank you thank you so what we
want to present today is not super
technical talk a bit more storytelling
talk about basically journey  that we had
to follow to really apply this project
and to come to the point where we had to
do ai in parks in Africa so you will
still have a bit of technical stuff of
we aamera trap with us if
you
ic for those here yesterday at  the
hugging face talk sorry because you will
also have lot more of French accents but
be with me doing my best
iwe so let's start this one let's be
polite this is us and SIM we are both
machine learning engineer thead machine
learning engineer on my side and  is my
team
we both have a computer science master
degree the only difference between us I
would say is that I did in China and I
love and did it in bolog and love
FO we work and it's important for for
the next because this is also the  how we
manage to it to our own company we both
work for a consulting company
ara bit more than 1000 peopleob
consultingusasic we for many compy we
are sold there we are doing project for
them a lot of big
Netherland and what we try to achieve
witha is  basically to combine business
people with tech people so really have
this strategical view together with the
technical and the engineering culture so
sometimes it work well sometimes you
have a bit of friction between the two but
the goal is to really add value using
data and that's also  why what we try to
do together with this
project why it's important also speak
about company which is Consulting it's
because to explain you a bit consultant
think they are super obsess about value
like everything they do should have
value because they are basically also
they cost a  lot of money for company so
they have to justify those cost and they
are very very obsessed about value but I
do believe to simplify that if you are
too obsessed about value and
specifically economical value you might
overlook other value like the societal
value one and that's  a bit the
motivation that P us to build this
project
one
mone so what we did back then was to
open a group together which weact hub
within the company that was really ping
for more sociact
project most of the time for free and
this is we  journeic together and this we
got first conta
and en
i
think and half and we to bit of extra
that we had a bit of time that we had
also in our work because Consulting it's
lot of workload and you don't have a lot
so  you can invest some time on personal
stuff and we use this time to build this
project that's how we met Smart Park so
that's the company we build the project
with that's ngas what
they do basically that they build a
lot of
ichyorder spaces so animalsas par and
basically protect and conserve the
environment so you have a picture of
Park you can have more on their
website that's basic we them and they
told us about Thea ofing in Afric so few
show on
re you have
AF
andul so the TR is going better because
we  man to make that curve go again but
still critically under and if you really
think
about a bit my business consulting
brand to say if I look on the
numbercic of ouris Africa and we estimate
that this loss is around 25 million
dollars a year so that's not nothing
just for elephant fist alone but it
also trigger my more impact part so my
my trust in humanity which is the lost
of biodiversity is not only dangerous
for the economy but it's also dangerous
for climate change and I also read
online that you can increase a lot  also
the number of diseases around the world so
we just had one Nice example of big
disease we don't want it to happen again [
Music]
of we can
disc just know that if you disrupt
ecosystem it will have impact on the
planet it will  impact on us one day
another so we are motivated to do it and
the idea and the ambition of the project
again was to use those camera trap that
you can see
here you can you can ever you and it
detects movement thanks to the to the
little device  here and it take pictures
really take picture of of everything
that's moving in front of it the goal of
it of this specific project was to
manage to develop from this camera trap
a machine learning pipeline that was
able to really take this picture analyze
the result  and display them in a way
that basically ranger and also any data
scientist work the project could detect
to human and human loc at B moment we
trigger an alarm so the ranger can just
go and check what's happening there I
would say second goal was to push  it
forward and to use it also Forli
monitoring so not only detect human but
also detect every kind of animal so if
you see that R is somewhere that is not
supposed to be maybe you wantck if
everything is going
right that was the
ambition we first really  wanted to focus
on open source technology so the smart
park is also working a l on op
technology on their side and this is a
bit the ecosystem that you can see today
on the left and on the middle around
life monitoring so those are technology
that are used  today for Life
monitoring and we wanted to check
Zoma basically which was the Open Source
model used by
companoud to detect and classy animals
in cameraap
the first really step that we took was
to benchmark a bit zom to some test with
zom to see if it  was really good for cas
or not and we started this journey so
just two graph two small experiments
that we did among a lot of other we did
try Z this open source package and we
did it on some test to to track see if
he was able  to detect humans because it
was the first and then we did it to see
if was able to detect blank blank because
you want that when your camera trigger
for nothing so there is a blank there
nothing on the picture you don't want to
send false alarm  to the ranger because
they will start to just go see there is
nothing they will lose their trust into
the and you will lose them and then they
will just stop working with you so
that's really not something we do we
want sorry so from this test we  see that
human really not satisfying
71% of accuracy we were far from what we
expected and on the blank labeling can
see
is
I because alltyure but most of the time
he detect basically m everywhere don't
ask me why it was one of the big
surprise we had so out of 30 picture I
think 20 20 on 20 picture he was
detecting m on the picture even though
there was absolutely nothing on the
picture so of course it was not as
simple as that we try to see if it was
easy to  tri etc but the conclusion of
this big ch marting s with zom
was we don't have a model that we want
it's noting enough for use case uh and
we don't have sadly the data and the
time to build our own model because it
need a lot of resource where we can put
is just some let's say one day every
every two week on the project we cannot
commit to do a lot more so let's use
just an API as a placeholder there so
the cloud vision API from Google on this
case and let's just focus on the
pipeline design so if later we find a
good model if someone super cool idea
and do like Open Source model we can
kind of plug it if you work in
machine learning you know it's not as
simple as that but that was  the idea
that we really drunk everything around the
model we develop the pipeline and if one
day we have a cool model we just plug it
to our
system and this is what we came off so
we just want before we dive into the
technical detail show you  a demo of what
we build and Simone will take over yeah
hello everyone so as said we developed B
web for scientist to like check the
results
of of our model in this case just at the
beginning of my talk I took a picture of
him and here  we have the results so um i
mean the the model we use i mean is like
cloud vision API so it's very generic
and detects everything that he finds in
a picture so also before like pant like
really whatever and our model our
approach also works with videos  so
before we also took a video just to test
that everything was working and as
you can see really detects everything so
it's not specific for animals or
like wildlife but for now at least at
the moment is very generic uh we also
have like a map  so here we can also
manage the camera traps so if I'm not
mistaken we have one here in in
Amsterdam like
right where we are so here and we can
also see some metadata about the camera
so the name the latitude longitude the
last detection and  so on and finally we
have just a page a configuration page
where you can add more camera traps or
change the details of the ones that are
already in place and at the same time we
also we were also able to integrate our
solution with an already existing
website called
ranger that is used by Rangers
in I mean Parks to
like I mean to monitor their wildli and
not only that and here we
create sort of alarm like where the
ranger can check the detection and also
like small
like note on what was detected and  based
on the image and like t
can on it so if I don't know
that was debt
likein somewhere that should not be can
like go there and check if everything is
going well or not yeah what you see is
really one for data scienti want  to
monitor the result of their model and
make sure the prediction MAK sense and
user is really the application that
ranger have in by So ranger this is the
one that you see this is notific and
they can basic theation they want from
theera and see if there  is or not yeah
so let's dig more into the
architecture so this is more or less the
overview of our solution so as soon as
the camera trap takes a picture it sends
an email to an email box with the
picture or the video attached then we
use  r that is driven tool to extract the
the attachment from the email and send
it to cloud
storage this like upload triggers a
cloud function that then calls the cloud
vision or cloud intelligence APIs uh
then we get the response from the API
and we save it to  bigquery and we save
the labeled image or video to cloud
storage we send B to like no red and
then from r we create like an alarm to
then push to ranger and at the same time
the web app develop using streamlit
reads from bigquery and the cloud
storage to then show on the web app
like the the results of the
detection and for yeah more or less in terms
of speed for a picture it takes
more or less 30 seconds to run end to
end the pipeline instead for a video
depends on course on  the length of the
video around
y to exp B the philosopher and why we make
choice
because in architecture design the
philosophy was to really keep everything
simple cheap fully automated and
scalable there was an additional part
using as much as possible Open Source
technology so if we  go back is open
source stream is open
sourceour
and it's an even driven architecture and
it's serverless so it's really cost
effective because you pay for what you
use really scale up so the more camera
you put cloud run basically which is a
service that is serving docker  container
towards the website can adapt to the to
the number of visitors the number of
people who go in cloud function the same
we trigger it like one per camera you
can go to multiple of function and it's
really cost effective as well and we
have also the  API that is for no really
bringing scability because you just pay
for the number of picture that you send
or number of that you send it's easy to
monitor and that's why we also developed
kind of this stream part to balance a
bit because you also you only  see the
good point there uh if you really want
to act fast 30 second 10 two minutes
maybe still a bit a bit a lot uh a lot
of delay also because we go on the cloud
and back so maybe if you really deploy
on the edge the  AI on the camera and if
you man to do it that's you can really
go from second to just less than so can
really Act faster there but it was a
nice demo that we can show and that was
the goal to illustrate also the cost
effective part  of course this is not
representative of intense usage in a
park but I think last month we pay 22
cents 22 of Euro just to keep everything
running so for hosting the webs
forosting prediction of theera et for
inf so you can see that quite for easy
to  main we have for theware andost
effective that was the goal that we had
because stillosted internally and the
goal is e to it on the cloud of the
potential Park we will collaborate with
or to keep it and see what we do with
the
cost the nextep on  this basically we dem
here we have I have a product you will
judge it at the end but the next step is
really we want to deploy it in a park so
either in Africa or in Europe we really
want to see the system in place because
of  course we can spend time on
optimizing the model doing evaluation
etc but I really want this product to
face the reality uh before we can really
decide what are the next step so that's
why we are still looking for contact the
person we work with together team have  a
lot of contact in Africa but still it's
too much of a risky investment for him
to deploy it
AF network
networkia so you have to build antennas
so our team knows how to do it but
it of
money to say in
short so we would like  to basic experim
it in Netherland potentially in
park thank
you
also with theue Park there is a lot
where we can Poti try to detect Wolf we
are still looking for contact if you
have any feel free to reach out after
this talk or scan the the QR  code if
they are big enough we also want to keep
monitoring uh the evolution of computer
vision so we are doing a bit of
technical watch if you have cool package
in mind if you know cool stuff we are
happy to take them to see where we can
focus our research next in order to
improve the modeling
part and we are also today open sourcing
theod
so it's mostly the code from the web app
but we also want to release some
tutorials you have an article on medium
from Simone that you can read so you  can
also replicate exactly the same stuff at
home you just need to buy the camera
don't ask me where you can find it I'm
just in contact with team there but the
goal is really to also ONP people to be
able to do them  uh on this specific
field i've seen a lot of academic stuff
happening but I never seen people taking
more like the practical approach of the
engineering approach on how do you
deploy in park so the goal is to open
source also methodology like covering
everything around  the model so people do
academics can also try Toly it on their
side and last next step I would say
build more documentation build more
feature continue to develop the package
keep the traction that's something we
want to do definitely as the next step
so if you are  also interested to
participate feel free to reach outend
it I think that's it for the talk to
question if you
[Applause]
any